this dude has been playing amazing love
it amazing today and I feel like it's
all of when I heard him speak I was this
dude nobody's playing crazy and then I
heard the little snippet like yo man I'm
trying to get this game back but the
craziest thing to me is that when we go
back earlier in the year and you think
back to the twt throughout 2019 you know
there's kind of this point where were
like man what happened to the Mossville
is what happened to the young Mossman
when is all the Japanese but they're all
kind of falling off right now we're
really right here in the final dip all
pulls it back together so many of them
in this top eight and no be shining
right now but he's going up against
Anakin here one of these guys is going
home
alright guys pop quiz hotshot if you
guys like your ma shinobi to take it
make some noise it's pretty good it's
pretty good I like it however if you
would like radiant's redbull Anakin to
take the set make some noise up there
guys Jack vs venom in this Tekken 7.0
yeah we did a lot of it oh this is
definitely true and like Anakin one of
those players who stuck to his current
rock look if you could trust anybody
it's character loyalist if they don't
change characters pretty sure they're
trustworthy person
look man nobody bounce around a little
bit but this is this is a dread putter
right here this is true I mean he was
saying that even in other tournaments
it's was only going to that now I would
love the scenes won't get more specific
with his wishes are dragging on
forgetting here he is rage boat now for
Novi and put the huge leap ducks behind
there's plenty for joe germaine anakin
told you at the end of the twt last year
he's like watch
checking them on the legs once again man
these small side steps have been adding
up for everybody you see it right there
and it's so small so slow that was
staring too close to the wall that time
and you can't be taking those kind of
risks but look at nobody just chopping
away pin that down to repeat offender he
just kept doing it I ain't even have to
tell him to do it again yeah beautiful
time in the no pictures not to get up
off the ground immediately while
standing for on top of it and it
definitely trying to get back those legs
not working out those side steps are
helping out no B he's gotta get ready
right so many down to his last round but
napkin with the duct get the log to the
wall carry crowds behind them Oh damage
that's gonna put a no beating rage okay
thanks
take it out the inks up two rounds to
one first down shut off the reef first
first down that's gone I don't know how
I didn't see that
Walter not quite mm-hmm on the side oh
wow look at that serious right there
veggies right back into it this is Matt
wait for Anna can't you just put Nobby
rage both of themI rage no we fight the
Russian assault final round Game one no
dependency I know you whoa another pair
definitely a counter bait and we've seen
him start to use those count as a lot
more another trade the ankles the
digital anklets once again keep tapping
upon to make nice block on the loaf once
again Anakin look at Mikey think all not
quite not close enough against the
counter hit on the slide shoot Oh get up
three charge of the down vector now rage
mode available gets the Block on it
though oh no me gonna get the game what
a comeback
what a finish man that was close man
that was close
Oh heartbreak central running it right
back no down time let's get right back
into it
game number two foot and devil in one of
those players feel like he has really
quick talk process gonna come to think
that he needs to do to clean backgrounds
the crowd behind hell yeah I heard them
what a step of know me though
picking up the walls right beside them
on the walls right there damage no sir
one down to once again those down Japs
definitely working out I don't remember
ever seeing him doing that that was
tight fellas sick forward to jackhammer
once again taken advantage by the
jackhammer this time look at the
pressure don't be so comfortable in
there right now
down for one you don't know no beat just
dominating right now just like that
set point for your bosses no beat foot
and Anakin find something he's got to do
something about this the pressure of
nobodies just relentless yeah he's just
not let him give me any time to breathe
oh my god yeah and that's doing a really
good job of stopping and it's all just
calm it stopping oh [ __ ] it shows lows
and love so much jackhammer more in
trying to get something started
oh boys why don't you not pressure
oh man the crowd can be a - now round
number four game - what Oh fun in small
punch
nice oh gosh oh my gosh oh no we going
to State select here that was crazy
how did he bring back he is the rematch
no we took the first two rounds I don't
like he shouldn't ice the beach and it
gave him some time but no and brings it
right back we're going on final game
nobody's like ok ok all right
oh good one feels pretty good let me let
me get back into this no crowd you
liking this one out there wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute is this not
so good at taking ladies and gentlemen
what I thought I could smell it
radiating back here radiant radiant
daddy
smooth game three final game between
these guys jambalaya post number two
let's get it okay once again the trade
and it can come through the aware you
can break the balcony I'll take the
shoulder look at the damage
oh yeah there we go the charge - yeah it
gave him a chance don't be took it I
need to do something pressure fame
advantage why I love that he's abusing
the wall bounce ridiculous it's not
gonna be enough to kill me cross chop
God be careful if it bill a timing down
that one Annika take the lead in the set
not the first time he's had the lead
know that we doesn't matter you need
three bubbles to win Manny three of
those bubbles being a lesbian rightful
down boy won't want to get the combo to
the wall with in the way range mode for
nobody now I'm gonna see some blue stuff
off the wall I don't think so wait for
bold that blue the flock for radiance
Red Bull Anakin versus nope
this is ridiculous okay here comes no me
he's gonna go with the crazy stuff here
he's got to the toilet pickle if he
lands the rage off you know range on
available now independent
going home but listen to the jet there's
like signaling us they out there but
they got the noise they chant going bro
that was ridiculous ridiculous damn it's
so damn good it's so damn good
I'm sorry Spencer it's so good it's so
good it's like Thanksgiving all over how
did he do that these are the best things
ever it's like Christmas so good oh my
god Anakin advancing to the top four of
the tournament with that win
what an incredible set I really thought
it was over his game too I thought he
was done he thought he we mad too fast
but no he brought it back out of his off
son
you know that clutch low Perry into the
rager combo